good afternoon and welcome back if you
were here this morning and welcome if
you just arrived for the afternoon
session I'm very pleased to introduce
Peter Schiffer elds vice provost for
research who'll give us a few thoughts
this afternoon on the topic of data and
data science peter is also a professor
of applied physics and physics here at
Yale he's a member of the American
Physical Society he's chair of the
division of material physics of the
society and past chair of the topical
group on magnetism in its applications
and if you don't know what that's about
talk to me later I'm sure I can explain
it probably no magic budget so without
further ado I'd like to welcome Peter
Schaffer all right Thank You Jill so it
is a genuine pleasure to be here and to
kick off the afternoon and I just want
to express first of all my gratitude to
everybody who has participated in the
organization of the event and putting
this together and all the speakers and
the panel members
this is really important for Yale and
I'm so glad that folks are helping put
it together and participating Yale is in
the midst of making a big push in
science and engineering it's an academic
priority and we are gearing up to make
it a reality this comes from president
salva is charged to us and it comes from
a sense of responsibility that Yale is
one of the great scholarly institutions
on the planet
has a responsibility to contribute in
science and engineering and there's a
sense of that from around campus sense
of that from our leadership and we're in
the midst of doing it and the
manifestation of that has been a long
process a couple year process of
strategic planning there was a wonderful
committee put together by the President
and provost led by Scott Strobel that
issued a very long report
90 odd pages I'm sure all of you have
read it in detail every one of you and
it it actually is a really really good
report and and it identified several
areas priority areas for increased
investment in the sciences and
engineering several cross-cutting themes
and several organizational structural
improvements that we should be making
and the reason I mention it not not just
because it's important to Yale as an
institution but also in this venue data
data science the structures that support
the use of data are prioritized in that
report more than anything else
data support is prioritized as an
organizational need the computational
resources to handle large data sets and
to analyze data are prioritized the
management of data are prioritized in
data science the fundamental mathematics
behind how we analyze data are
prioritized that's actually the first
among the top priority areas slated for
additional investment data are
incredibly important and I know I'm
preaching to the choir here but I just
want to emphasize that just like
everything else in society research is
being transformed by the availability of
massive sets of data it's it's different
from research that was conducted 10 20
30 years ago in the sense the the
quantity of data that's available the
fidelity of the data to reality and the
computational resources that we have our
hands that allow us to analyze the data
it's just it's a different world for
research and that goes across the full
spectrum of the scholarly enterprise
from the arts and humanities the social
sciences which oh you'll hear my
colleague Alan Gerber in a minute to all
of the Natural Sciences and engineering
every single field is being
pacted by the ability to collect or
gather or acquire large datasets and
then analyze them and that's wonderful
it allows us to do things that we
couldn't have dreamed of doing 10 20 30
years ago but it comes with a
responsibility because the people
federal government foundations
corporations that give us money to that
allows us to do our research they know
that we can use data now and so they
have higher expectations they have
expectations that we'll use it but also
expectations that we'll handle the data
appropriately all the privacy concerns
and the use concerns when it's
proprietary data and that we'll manage
it appropriately and this is something
that universities are learning how to do
is when we not just bring in data to use
but we create our own data where do we
put it and how do we store it and the
old model which you know I was raised in
where the PhD student would hand a hard
drive to the adviser upon graduating and
then wave goodbye and the the hard drive
would sit on the advisors shelf until
there were advisor moved offices and
then couldn't figure out what it was and
threw in the trash that model is no
longer acceptable it turns out so coming
up with the mechanisms to handle the
data that we create is going to be part
of what we do as well as having the
ability to bring in datasets and use
other people's data responsibly and
there's a lot of effort around that and
a lot of very high expectations from the
government and other funders for how we
do that fortunately at Yale we have
tremendous resources to help researchers
with that sitting right in front of me
and being in this building the library
is first and foremost among those but
also the Yale Center for research
computing I TS and the administrative
offices that help us deal with our
sponsors office of sponsored research
the also cooperative research on and on
and on we have lots of support here and
with the science priorities we're just
going to have to
building and building on that room that
support and it's gonna be the
responsibility of each one of us
involved in research enterprise to think
about how we acquire data how we use the
data and for the data we create what
happens to it when we're done and where
it where it goes and to make sure that's
in line with best practices so with that
let me say again thank you thank you to
everybody who helped with the stay
together thank you to those of you who
are here for the afternoon and to all
the speakers and unfortunately not gonna
able to stick around for the whole
afternoon aha but I'm really looking
forward to hearing what I can please
enjoy and do great things with data
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]